este sábado como bien lo decía se van a
reunir jefes de estado y de gobierno
para firmar ya finalmente la declaración
de Santo Domingo que ayer quedó
prácticamente lista por parte de los
cancilleros de los ministros de
exteriores y básicamente se van a
adoptar tres documentos iberoamericanos
por un lado la carta medioambiental
iberoamericana por otro lado la de
derechos digitales además de un plan de
ruta crítico para atajar la inseguridad
alimentaria que recordemos según la FAO
afecta a más del 40% de la población de
la región pero tal y como avanzamos aquí
en exclusiva en France 24 ayer dado que
tuvimos acceso a un borrador de esta
declaración se cae el que era uno de los
Pilares de esta Cumbre y era la petición
a conjunta para una nueva arquitectura
financiera que permitiera a los países
de la región acceder más fácilmente a
los créditos y a los préstamos
internacionales finalmente no ha habido
consenso en este punto tampoco hay a
destacar no según vimos en este borrador
una condena ni una mención explícita
siquiera a la cuestión de la guerra en
Ucrania pero sí un punto en que se
recalca la intención de trabajar para la
paz completa y para poner fin a las a
los efectos adversos de Las Guerras
bueno Rosa y otra de las grandes
noticias de ayer viernes fue finalmente
la noticia de que Nicolás Maduro
asistirá hoy a la Cumbre Cómo fue
recibida allí en Santo Domingo
pues Rodrigo te cuento que llegó esta
noticia de una forma bastante inesperada
y confusa de hecho por eso mismo
muchísima gente lo pasó por alto no sin
embargo a nosotros nos llamó muchísimo
la atención y ayer mismo ya lo avanzamos
Y es que lo que sucedió es que en medio
de la ceremonia inaugural la
presentadora del acto estaba mencionando
a los líderes internacionales que no
estaban todavía en Santo Domingo pero
que sí que estaban llegando al país para
asistir hoy allá a esta cumbre de jefes
de estado y de gobierno y entre los
nombres que mencionó mencionó el de
Nicolás maduro que hasta el momento ni
había confirmado ni desmentido no su
asistencia pero digamos que es no no se
acaba de esperar después de que tampoco
asistiera a la celac ni al anterior
Cumbre iberoamericana bien esta noticia
ya fue confirmada ya no fue confirmada
por la cancillería de Venezuela además
insistimos en que según el borrador al
que tuvimos acceso hay un punto
establecido precisamente reivindicado
por Venezuela y es el que hace
referencia a condenar las medidas
coercitivas unilaterales que atentan
contra la carta de las Naciones Unidas y
contra el derecho internacional En
referencia a las sanciones que pesan
sobre Caracas y Simplemente ya para
acabar de mencionar lo que sucedió ayer
pues Vimos a Luis abinader el anfitrión
de esta Cumbre recibir a muchos de los
mandatarios regionales no a pues Arce
borich Fernández
Xiomara Castro para mencionar solamente
algunos pero se hicieron notar ayer más
que en cualquier ocasión las grandes
ausencias a esta Cumbre amlo o Lula no
por sus por el gran peso de sus países
en la región pero también por ejemplo
bukele o boluarte por lo protagonistas
que son en estos momentos de la
actualidad política regional tampoco
estaba Ayer todavía Pedro Sánchez
mientras se le mencionaba no mientras el
secretario iberoamericano mencionaba la
importancia de que España
vaya a presidir el consejo de la Unión
Europea para acercar la región europea
con el latinoamerica